I'm Chris guy and I'm here at the
roaster Bruce Willis with the one and
only Flula Borg
what did you say cool look Flula Borg no
no my name is kuba somebody's at the
roast
I plan to look Ron in the face and say
Tom I'm not dead
big boy I'm here I'm ready let's blow
some up at the end of the movie you
died because you fell off the roof but
you're here tonight so how exactly do
you make it after that did you not see
the swimming pool there was a swimming
pool but I'm an Olympian swimmer have
you met Mark Spitz a seven-time gold
medal winner
according I am Mark Spitz I don't know
if you can tell but you're making me
very hot and I notice you're perspiring
very do you think it'll be better to
wrap an art museum or a jewelry store it
depends on how much jewelry is in the
jewelry store if it's under 50,000 euros
I won't touch it
what about in pounds whatever the money
was in pair Oh hide your pants
yeah I'm into crypto now I'm getting
very deep into crypto so did you invest
in Bitcoin I've created my own coin
group coin so I would like some groups
can we talk about invested in groups
later yes I will give you my exchange
right off the air thank you sir would
you change anything about how you
execute your plan yes I would have held
on to halogen arrows risk not a
wristwatch we all thought the same the
gravity as they say
you